ça c'est quand je suis arrivé ici à
montréal j'avais 6 ans né au liban et
rescapé de la guerre civile qui a fait
rage de 1975 à 1990 la musicienne
montréalaise lamia raid n'a pas fermé
l'oeil depuis l'explosion qui a détruit
selon elle le poumon culturel de
beyrouth
et puis trois jours en flip les images
là facebook toutes les réseaux sociaux
on veut voir ce qui se passe pour
étudier et partager en occident la
musique du moyen orient la bia yared et
maintes fois retourner au liban
l'explosion a frappé le quartier qu'elle
a habité entre 2009 et 2013
y a plein d'amis autour de moi qui sont
en colère bien sûr moi je vis ça d'une
façon que j'ai mal en pleine écriture de
son quatrième roman l'écrivain et dj
d'origine libanaise dimitri nasrallah
est inquiet presque l'explosion
nucléaire ça le c'était le cas ma
première chose que je pensais
après ça médiatement c'était la peur
pour la famille j'ai encore beaucoup de
fer familal et entre les anglais cousine
les cous est toujours très attaché au
liban le drame qui se joue présentement
est symptomatique selon lui d'un
problème plus vaste et c'est pas si mon
explosion
c'était un crise financière qui a
commencé depuis quatre mois c'était le
cas au vide sur ça il y avait un
question de transportation qui est
vraiment plus grand concert que ça les
gens perdus plus que 80% de leurs de la
valeur de l'or
argent près de deux cent vingt mille
canadiens se considèrent d'origine
libanaise rawi hage et l'un d'eux arrivé
au canada en 1991
l'écrivain a clamé à l'international
voit aujourd'hui le quartier de son
enfance détruit par l'explosion
je suis toujours en contact avec les
familles des membres de ma famille était
blessé et notre maison la maison
d'autres membres de famille
les voisins tout est détruit et comme
plusieurs l'artiste souhaite que l'aide
étrangère s'organise
c'est un lieu de rencontre de plusieurs
cultures et je trouve que culturellement
est ce que ça le présent c'est important
un pays un pays et il faut pas lâcher
tandis que la situation demeure
incertaine au liban lamia raid
dimitri nasrallah et rawi hage sont de
tout coeur avec ce pays qui les habitent
ici
louis philippe ouimet radio canada morin